the alliance between France and Germany
is often described as the engine of the
European Union it's been sputtering
since last year when Emmanuel macron
canceled this meeting after a series of
disagreements with Berlin over defense
and energy policy in the wake of the war
in Ukraine differences that affect
policy making in the rest of the EU
every time when there is a major
decision to be taken the two countries
may have different approaches but in the
end it's only when they agree that the
27 can agree so we are in that process
at the moment on different issues one is
obviously the Ukraine war and how to
support Ukraine and we've seen in recent
days that Chancellor Charles has been
under a lot of criticism for his
reluctance to send thanks to to Ukraine
and from the German Chancellor on Sunday
still no commitment that he'll give
Ukraine what it wants
the U.S is doing a lot Germany is also
doing a lot we have constantly expanded
our supplies with very effective weapons
that are already available today and
we've always closely coordinated all
these decisions with all our important
allies and friends with France for
example with the US with other major
countries in Europe and of course with
all those who participate in this
discussion Emmanuel macron says France
has not ruled out sending its tanks but
needs to consider three criteria
firstly that's what we've been able to
do since the beginning that it does not
escalate secondly that it could bring
real effective support to our Ukrainian
friends
and for this we must consider the
capacity to maintain them in operational
conditions and training
both leaders reaffirmed a commitment to
support Ukraine as long as necessary
Latvia Lithuania and Estonia have added
to the calls from other countries to
send tanks to Ukraine piling the
pressure on Berlin the new German
defense minister says he'll visit Kiev
soon he can expect one subject to
dominate the agenda
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera Paris
Julian Hertz is a European policy
specialist and editor of the French
dispatch he says Germany and France have
put aside their political differences to
help push for a more Sovereign Europe
back in October last year there was a
very real situation that could have
spilled into a very dangerous situation
but now things have stabilized and we
need to remember that there are a lot of
similarities and points in common
between Emmanuel macro and Olaf Schultz
such as the wish to push for more
Sovereign Europe and increasing the
investments in defense and the European
industry there's a lot of similarities
and a lot of cohesion on topics of
increasing European sovereignty dealing
with the current economic plan of Joe
Biden in the states and finding a
European solution to this that combines
all the efforts of European States
investing further in defense and
industries so making sure that European
Defense is up to scratch and also that
the European industry can compete on the
global scale however one of the big
things that has caused some issues is
how to go about ensuring a European
sovereignty and particularly autonomy
for example macron favors an EU
sovereignty fund that finances
investment across the EU but Olaf
Schultz and the STP are against this
because the fact that effectively this
would lead to more European debt which
has always been a German Red Line no
matter who the chancellor has been and
this is something where they're going to
have to work together but if we are
entirely honest the role of the Franco
German engine is to lead the way take on
the tough discussions find Solutions and
also bring everybody to the table start
the right solution can be found for
everybody in the EU